[Musique]
merci Philippe mouier d'avoir accepté
notre invitation élu des deux sèves
membres du groupe les républicains
président de la commission des affaires
sociales et auteur d'une proposition de
loi sur les retraites agricoles dont on
va parler dans quelques instants mais
d'abord on l'a vu dans le journal
l'actualité c'est François Baayou qui
n'entrera donc pas au gouvernement faute
d'accord profond sur la politique à
suivre est-ce que ça veut dire que le
virage à droite est acté lui qui
demandait un recentrage je sais pas si
c'est problème du virage à droite de
politique ou c'est plus la personnalité
de François baayrou je comprends qu'il a
souhaité les lumières au lendemain de sa
relaxe mais le principe de dire je
choisis mon ministère et je et si j'ai
pas ce que je veux je claque la porte
c'est d'un côté je suis prêt à être en
accord avec le gouvernement si j'ai le
bon ministère en désaccord si je n'ai
pas ce que je veux donc je trouve que
c'est plutôt un triste spectacle et ça
renforce ni la majorité aujourd'hui ni
l'image de François bayerou est-ce que
ça la divise cette majorité est-ce que
pour vous cette majorité présidentielle
est en train de voler en éclat alors
François Baou qui dit qu'ilentre soit
pas au gouvernement mais que les
ministres modemes restent au
gouvernement pour vous il y a un
paradoxe oui complètement c'estd que
voilà on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui on
n'est pas sur un débat de ligne
politique mais vraiment de personnalité
d'ego moi je crois que aujourd'hui on a
besoin d'autres choses pour réagir au
niveau du gouvernement et surtout
d'avoir très rapidement je dirais
l'ossature du gouvernement alors dans
ces dans ces justification il pointe
quand même certaines choses notamment il
dit qu'il y a un goufre qui s'est creusé
entre la province et Paris il parle de
crise de l'aménagement du territoire il
vis juste oui je pense qu'il a raison
mais je suis très étonné qu'il découvre
maintenant euh j'ai à un moment donné
c'est un observateur averti du le monde
politique on voit bien que ce
décollage existe prement depuis le début
et il il s'emplifie au fur et à mesure
des réformes voilà donc je suis surtout
très étonné de de la temporarité de sa
remarque sur la suite du romanement il
se fait trop attendre pour vous oui oui
beaucoup parce qu'on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui il y a plein de dossiers
qui sont dans l'attente il y a plein de
de réformes nécessaires qui sont
aujourd'hui tenus par l'administration
donc il y a urgence je pense vraiment
que notre pays a besoin d' certain
nombre de réformes et que sans ministres
GIS à temps plein sur l'ensemble des
dossiers aujourd'hui on est en
difficulté vous souhaitez l'entrée de
sénateur dans ce gouvernement je
souhaite surtout l'entrée de de gens qui
des talents des compétences et une
vision réelle de ce qui se passe partout
en France donc voilà donc et les
sénateurs permettrai ça de combler ce
gouffre entre Paris et la province don
par sénateur pourra mais je crois que
c'est pas le sujet le sujet c'est ça
dépend des personnalité et je trrois
qu'aujourd'hui voilà il y a un vrai
sujet de difficulté on a plein de talent
c'est là on mais voilà je crois que
c'est pas la la question n'est pas posée
aujourd'hui il faut de nouveau LR je
suis pas certain non plus je crois que
vous l'avez dit il y a déjà un virage à
droite qui été mais virage à droite de
par la personnalité des ministres pas
forcément de la politique qui est
appliqué même si on voit bien on est
toujours dans le même temps un peu à
droite un peu à gauche moi aujourd'hui
ce que je veux surtout c'est une ligne
conductrice qui qui enfin je dirais un
axe pour lequel on puisse accompagner
une vraie réforme pour la France on va
parler de l'autre actualité là aussi on
l'a vu dans le journal c'est cet hommage
qui était présidé hier par Emmanuel
Macron mat national aux victimes team
française de l'attaque du Hamas le 7
octobre dernier vous étiez présent
qu'est-ce que vous avez ressenti pendant
ce moment beaucoup beaucoup d'émotion je
crois que d'abord le le discours du prés
République pardon était était juste avec
le bon ton les mots étaient posés et je
crois que tout a été dit c'était
l'essentiel et on s'est retrouvé dans
une forme de solidarité dire politique
autour autour de cette de cette terrible
crise avec des familles qui étaient
également présentes je crois que voilà
c'était
nécessaire et vraiment je trouve que
c'était une belle cérémonie chargée
d'émotion et j'espère que ça va envoyé
un message en tout cas à l'ensemble de
la communauté française mais d'une façon
générale à tous ceux qui réagissent
regardent ce en avait besoin est-ce
qu'elle est suffisamment s soutenue par
la nation pardon cette communauté
Française juive alors je pense que oui
mais même si on peut faire toujours
mieux hein voilà mais on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui il y a voilà face à
l'horreur on est forcément solidaire
voilà mais je crois qu'il faut être
prudent faut retirer des enseignements
et puis il faut surtout avoir cette
capacité de dire à un moment donné on
fait unité autour de tout ça c'est pas
le débat d' juif ou pas on fait unité
autour de de ce qui est improbable voilà
des massacre on peut pas tolérer donc à
partir de là on a un vrai message à
porter al unité nationale mais il y a
quand même une polémique hier sur la
présence des élus de la France insoumise
lors de cet hommage alors qu'il n'avait
pas participé à la marche contre
l'antisémitisme et qu'ils ont eu des
déclarations ambigues sur le Hamas
est-ce que cette présence était
opportune je peux pas vraiment enfin je
veux pas rentrer dans cette polémique il
y a quelques personnalités qu'on des
propos tellement difficiles je comprends
que les familles réagit négativement
globalement l'idée c'était avant tout
une unité nationale donc ça dépasse les
partis politiques après que chacun se
regarde dans le miroir entre les
déclarations que l'on peut faire sur des
plateaux les messages envoyés auprès de
la population et puis la présence d'hier
voilà mais moi je retiens surtout c'est
le discours du président de la
République et peut-être le regard des
familles et le président de la
République l'Élisée qui envisage un
temps également dommage aux victimes
françaises à Gaza est-ce que ça vous
paraît opportun je crois qu'on est dans
la même logique c'estd que à partir de
la d' alors qu'on considère que on doit
avoir un message fort vis-à-vis de de de
de ceux qui souffrent et notamment de de
ressortis français je crois que c'est
une même logique on va parler de la
crise agricole on parlera des retraites
agricoles dans quelques instants mais
d'abord plus généralement sur cette
crise est-ce que pour vous Gabriel Atal
a bien réussi à éteindre le feu alors je
pense qu'il a réussi à éteindre le feu
par un certain nombre de déclarations
mais aujourd'hui il est sous observation
et les bresses sont encore là et on
regarde ce qui va se passer dans les
prochains jours et notamment on se
rapproche du salon d'agriculture hein
euh je pense que le monde agricole ne
pourra pas se satisfaire uniquement de
déclaration maintenant il faut des actes
et donc voilà donc vraiment on est en
phaseobservation il y a une temporarité
qui fait que voilà on renvoie vers le
salon de l'agriculture mais aujourd'hui
il y a voilà les les dans dans tout le
territoire national on voit bien que le
monde agricole est en ébullition a
raison d'ailleurs et donc aujourd'hui il
faut vraiment une traduction concrète
des revendications et surtout des
promesses faites par le gouvernement
alors on va écouter justement le
président des Jeunes Agriculteurs Arnaud
qui était auditionné hier par les
sénateurs il a parlé du sentiment de
malêtre de ses agriculteurs notamment dû
à la question des normes et des Galim on
l'écoute ce sentiment quand même de
finalement toujours plus mais finalement
sans contrôler ce qui rentre chez nous
sur
l'alimentation ce sentiment de vouloir
toujours faire mieux même au sein de
l'Europe avec des normes qui sont pas
forcément respectées ailleurs en Europe
et au-delà de ça je pense un un autre
vrai problème c'est le le sentiment de
mal-être agricole qui qui pêche chez
beaucoup de gens n'empêche qu'il
s'exprimait c'est ce sentiment fait
finalement d'être toujours la la le
responsable le responsable du mal-être
des animaux le responsable de cet
environnement qui est en train de se
détruire finalement le responsable de
tous les mots qu'il y auraiit sur cette
planète à l'heure actuelle et bien sûr
un sujet en lien avec leurevenue et bah
l'application pleine entière des galimes
sur ce dernier point d'abord sur Galim
est-ce que les contrôles et les
sanctions annoncées par le gouvernement
sont suffisants est-ce que pour vous ça
va porter ses fruits alors suffisant non
je pense que nécessaire oui suffisant
non parce que je crois que aujourd'hui
il faut un accompagnement je dirais très
rapproché du gouvernement
d'administration pour que égalim
s'applique réellement je vous rappelle
que ce qui est en train de se passer
nous avions alerté à l'époque au Sénat
au moment du vote du texte sur le risque
de déséquilibre et on y est aujourd'hui
donc on voit bien que il y a besoin d'un
accompagnement il y a besoin d'un peu de
pression voilà il y a des règles du jeu
à définir aujourd'hui VO c'est
nécessaire moi j'entends l'intervention
du prés des jeun agriculteurs je crois
que il y a aussi un mot qui manque dans
dans dans dans dans dans dans ces propos
quelque part c'est le sentiment
d'injustice et le sentiment d'injustice
ça crée à un moment donné des
difficultés énormes et à mal-être
profond parce que on on un moment donné
on définit des règles on fait quelque
part miroiter enfin une solution et dans
l'application on est en décalage
pourquoi parce queà un moment donné les
texes sont présents ce qui est déjà
énorme mais on n'est pas capable de les
appliquer et puis il y a tout le
contournement que l'on connaît je crois
que voilà on a l'outil il est là il faut
vraiment le mettre en application et
puis là il y a urgence clairement quoi
il pointe aussi la question des normes
parmi les causes du malêtre des
agriculteur est-ce que Gabriel Atal a eu
raison de mettre un peu le frein oui il
a raison mais de nouveau il faut faut
qu'on le traduise là on est encore dans
le discours alors à la fois il faut
trouver l'équilibre entre les enjeux
environnementaux qu'on peut pas balayer
mais en même temps la capacité à être je
dirais équitable sur les marchés lors
que voilà on connaît tous le sujet on se
donne des contraintes à notre
agriculteur en France pendant qu'on
importe des produits ex ur donc il faut
à la fois cet équilibre et puis il faut
accompagner le monde agricole dans le
changement donner interdiction donner
une limite sans apporter je dirais les
moyens de d'adaptation pour les
exploitations agricoles c'est une vraie
difficulté on peut pas simplement
pointer du doigt en disant voilà ça se
passe comme ça vous navez déjà pas de
revenu mais en plus on vous met des des
normes supplémentaires il y a un
véritable accompagnement voilà donc moi
je pose pas les deux je pense qu'il faut
être dans la même démarche mais on doit
accompagner ce pour qui on demande à la
fois de nourrir la France mais en même
temps de sad adapter de et de faire
éuler leur modèle parmi les
revendications et les inquiétudes des
agriculteurs il y a la question de leur
retraite trop faible c'est pour remédier
à cette situation vous avez déposé une
proposition de loi le 31 janvier dernier
pour vous il y avait urgence à agir on
va voir le détail de votre texte avec
Marion
[Musique]
Vigreux bonjour Marion bonjour bonjour
monie le sénateur et Marion avant de
regarder précisément ce que contient le
texte de Philippe Mouillet on va
redonner quelques éléments
oui petit retour en arrière en février
2023 il y a 1 an le Sénat et l'Assemblée
nationale adopté un texte de loi visant
à calculer la retraite de base des non
salariés agricoles c'est-à-dire les
chefs d'exploitation en se basant sur
les 25 années les plus avantageuse et
non plus sur l'intégralité de la
carrière l'idée étant d'adopter pour ces
non salariés agricoles la règle qui
prévaut pour les travailleurs du régime
général petite parenthèse on rappelle
que les retraites agricoles sont
nettement inférieur à la moyenne des
retraité avec 800 € par mois en 2020
contre 1520 € pour l'ensemble des
retraité après le vote du Parlement
l'exécutif avait 3 mois pour évaluer
l'impact de cette réforme et pour
préciser les modalités de sa mise en
œuvre or pendant quasiment un an ce
rapport est resté aux abonnés absents et
le monde agricole comme les sénateurs et
députés notamment les républicains s'en
sont agacés dont vous Philippe Mouillet
vous estimez que le gouvernement a
traîné sur ce dossier là tout à fait
donc d'où notre action vous l'avez très
bien dit dans le calendrier hein le
texte de loi alors avait l'avantage
quand même de fixer les règles le
principe général des 25 meilleures
années mais derrièur la traduction hein
entre le le discours les promesses et la
traduction c'était un rapport qui devait
envoyer ensuite la écriture d'un décret
et donc dès lors que le rapport était je
dirais d'abord dans les tablettes je
rappelle simplement que c'est parce que
nous avons à un moment donné la
commission affffaires sociales sollicité
le gouvernement en disant nous allons
mandater officiellement la demande de ce
rapport que d'un seul coup le rapport
est apparu dans la journée même et donc
nous avons fait la lecture de ce rapport
en constatant que les scénarios qui
étaient proposés ne correspondaient pas
aux responsabilités on va y revenir
juste un mot vous nous confirmez que
tous les groupes étaient à l'unisson
autour de de ce projet de loi oui oui
globalement on avait on avait à la fois
de de de deux phénomènes il y a la loi
chassenne qui définissait un minimum
pour les retraites et puis ce principe
général voilà donc on voit bien il y il
y a eu globalement un vote conforme
entre les entre les deux chambres et
donc il fallait rentrer en application
quoi on va parler de ce rapport puisque
vous le disiez le Parlement l'a enfin
reçu oui donc c'était le le 30 janvier
dernier ce rapport il a été rédigé
notamment par liigas qui avait été
mandaté par l'exécutif les experts ont
donc travailler sur trois scénarios et
selon la
majorité scénatoriale et vous-même
aucune des propositions qui se trouvve
dans ce rapport n'est conforme au texte
initial voté au Parlement il y aurait à
vos yeux plus de perdants avec les
scénarios de Ligas oui tout à fait
arrêtez on jeis que le texte était
conforme à ce qui était voté mais
simplement dans la traduction on voit
bien que techniquement et bien quand on
fait les simulations le nombre de
perdant est important en même temps vous
avez parfois même dans les scénario des
décalage jusqu'à 2040 pour l'application
donc on n'était pas dans l'esprit de la
loi et donc à partir de là les scénarios
étant défavorables on imaginait ce que
pouvit être le décret ou finalement le
non décret j'était resté dans dans le
standby sans décision et donc il il y
avait quand même dans le rapport un
scénario qui était celui que quelque
part que j'ai repris dans cette PPL qui
avait été travaillé au Sénat notamment
par Pascal grunny qui était rapporteur
de de la branche la branche vieillesse
mais ce scénario était cité sans être
développé et travaillé et à partir de là
et bien on a pris nos responsabilité on
s dit puisque on ne peut pas avoir une
maîtrise complète du sujet puisqu'on
renvoie par un décret au regarde un
rapport qui ne convient pas et bien on a
souhaité inscrire dans le dur le
principe général très rapidement est-ce
que vous trouvez que Ligas a bien fait
son travail bah je moi je vrais surtout
voir quelle était la la lettre de
mission de Ligas j'imagine que Ligas
d'une façon générale Ligas fait bien son
travail voilà mais quelle était la
lretion générale des affaires sociales
voilà donc voilà donc simplement ce que
je que j'ai la traduction c'est que le
rapport ne correspond pas à l'esprit de
la loi qui a été voté il y a un an et
donc vous avez contre-attaqué en
déposant effectivement en urgence une
proposition de loi c'était le 31 janvier
dernier Cigné par les sénateurs LR dans
celle-ci vous proposez donc un autre
scéario c'est un mode de calcul où le
système de régime agricole par point et
conservé c'est bien ça et conservé et
donc on on va chercher je dirais les 25
meilleures années de la carrière on fait
une moyenne et à partir de là on
l'applique à l'ensemble des années de
travailler à tout plein voilà et avec ce
principe là et bien globalement il y a
pas de perdant au pire il y a y a
certains ont une progression qui est
limitée mais globalement tous le tous
les tous les exploitants agcoles sont
gagnants et donc on est plus proche de
l'esprit alors avec derrière comme
incidence un coup puisque globalement on
peut pas annoncer euh un mode de calcul
qui doit favoriser améliorer les
retraites sans qu'il y ait un coût sur
la table donc nous on a même estimé le
coût en grande transparence hein à peu
près 470 millions d'euros serait le coût
lorsque la réforme sera appliquée en G
en plein fonctionnement et avec une
capacité de l'appliquer dès 2026
puisqu'il faut laisser le temps euh je
dirais aux opérateurs euh de de mettre
en place les les les modèles mais voilà
donc là on est l'avantage d'être dans un
texte de loi qui correspond exactement à
l'esprit de la loi et donc il a même
plus besoin de décret si le gouvernement
il peut tout de suite appliquer les
choses avec je dirais le le guide qu'on
vient de au Sénat vous évoqueiez le coût
annuel de 470 millions d'euros Bruno
rotaillo a dit que c'est le coût pour
réparer une injustice vous le penser
aussi oui complètement complètement
c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui alors que
globalement on est quand même plutôt
dans un esprit de recherche d'économie
ici au Sénat mais il faut savoir parfois
bouger bouger les curseurs lorsqu'on
considère que il y a besoin de
réparation vous avez très bien expliqué
le décalage qu'il y a entre les
retraites je dirais des des de monde
salariés et du monde agricole
aujourd'hui il y a un engagement qui a
été pris il a été soutenu par l'ensemble
je dirais des groupes politiques le
gouvernement fait l'annonce et bien
concrètement il faut avoir la
responsabilité de considérer qu'il y a
un coût supplémentaire que la solidité
nationale doit pouvoir financer donc
avec cette PPL votre intention est de
faire pression sur le gouvernement si
rien ne se passe ce texte sera à l'ordre
du jour dans 2 mois vous avez d'ailleurs
déjà un rapporteur désigné la sénatrice
Pascale Gruny Gabriel attel a fait
savoir qu'il voulait poursuivre les
investigation sur la question des
retraites agricoles hier le député
Julien div qui était l'auteur de la prop
position de loi de février 2023 devait
rencontrer le Premier ministre on ne
sait pas vous ne savez pas si cette
rencontre a eu lieu pousse pensez-vous
néanmoins pouvoir à terme obtenir gain
de cause oui enfin gain de cause surtout
faire en sorte que le gouvernement et
bien aille jusqu'au bout de C de ses
engagements donc aujourd'hui on a une
situation où le gouvernement peut
prendre la main et plus important pour
nous c'est le résultat final hein il
peut prendre la main parce que la loi d'
permet au gouvernement par un décret de
mettre en place cette réforme voilà si
jamais il n'avance pas ou si la réforme
ne correspond pas aux engagements et
bien nous avons nous l'outil nous avons
aujourd'hui un moyen de d'afficher
clairement notre position et donc 2 mois
pour pouvoir mettre à l'ordre du jour si
le gouvernement prend ses
responsabilités avant nous retirerons
cette proposition de loiord du jour on
est vraiment dans le rôle du Parlement
de dire à un moment donné il y a un
engagement on est techniquement au point
pour pouvoir proposer une réforme juste
et en plus on assume le coût financier
voilà je crois qu'aujourd'hui il y a
tous les ingrédients très franchement je
ne comprendrais pas pourquoi le
gouvernement enclencherait pas cette
réforme est-ce que cette question des
retraites agricoles elle a évidemment un
impact pour pour les agriculteurs
concernés mais est-ce qu'elle a aussi un
impact sur l'avenir de l'agriculture
est-ce que ça freine la transmission
également oui alors d'une façon générale
enfin je crois que on a eu le témoignage
tout à l'heure tous les tous les signaux
sont au rouge dans le monde agricole
donc c'est difficile d'expliquer à un
jeune de reprendre une exploitation
agcole de mettre des capitaux importants
pour reprendre exploitation l'école sans
être certain d'avoir non seulement un
revenu descent pendant je dirais la vie
de travail mais en plus avoir une
retraite qui est en dessous je dirais du
du niveau général donc voilà ça fait
partie d'un ensemble la retraite est un
po essentiel et puis on aujourd'hui on a
clairement des des gens enfin moi je
dans mon département qui ont des niveaux
de retraite ils sont clairement en
difficulté aujourd'hui hein donc ils ont
travailler toute leur vie ils ont fait
une démarche je dirais d'investissement
pendant toute leur vie et avec un niveau
de retraite qui est minimum donc voilà
je crois que c'est un un point essentiel
et c'est un vrai sujet de justice
sociale il y a un texte justement qui
est attendu par du gouvernement sur le
renouvel des génération qui a d être
présenté en janvier qui a été reporté
pour cause de crise agricole qu'est-ce
que vous attendez de ce texte ah je
crois que d'abord un c'est un signal qui
doit être porté auprès des jeunes
générations voilà et ce que j'espère à
travers ce texte là c'est comment est-ce
qu'on aide comment on accompagne ce
renouvellement parce que on l'a dit il y
a d'abord un niveau de revenu d'activité
donc ça renvoie la lo Galim au partage
je dirais de la marge mais c'est auudelà
de ça c'est comment est-ce qu'on
accompagne parce qu'une transmission
d'une explo agricole c'est compliqué ça
nécessite des moyens financiers
importants alors quand vous êtes dans
dans le cadre familial c'est un peu plus
simple quand vous êtes hors cadre
familial et bien comment est-ce qu'on
fait comment est-ce qu'on peut apporter
un tutor comment est-ce qu'on peut
mobiliser des moyens capitalistiques
pour pouvoir faire l'accompagnement
comment on peut faire en sorte que ceux
qui cent leur entreprise puissent
accompagner leurpreneur on a un certain
nombre d'outi au Sénat on a largement
travaillé sur le sujet donc on pourra
accompagner cette réforme mais elle est
nécessaire donc vous voyez il y a à la
fois la retraite pour gérer la la fin de
carrière mais il y a surtout le
démarrage comment on fait pour redonner
au vie au aux jeunes qui sont
globalement sensibiliser dans les zones
rurales autour du monde agricole mais
comment leur donner une perspective
d'avenir quoi merci Marion à tout à
l'heure on va parler des normes oui de
la enfin toujours dans le domaine
agricole on parlera de la simplification
des normes promis et gouvernement ce
sera à suivre dans le club on va voir
l'actualité dans votre région pour
terminer on va retrouver Jefferson des
sport bonjour Jefferson merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous Jefferson de Sud-Ouest
Jefferson vous allez nous parler vous
d'une expérimentation qui a débuté en
Gironde sur la sécurité sociale de
l'alimentation
oui exactement à partir du mois d'avril
400 personnes en Gironde vont PIR et
tester ce dispositif alors concrètement
chaque foyer va toucher 150 € plus 75 €
par personne en sous forme de monnaie
numérique cet argent sera à dépenser
dans des magasins engagés auprès des
producteurs locaux le dispositif repose
sur des aides publiques du conseil
départemental et de la ville de Bordeaux
notamment mais aussi sur un système de
cotisation l'idée étant de pouvoir
s'autofinancer
ma question pour Philippe Moulier et
celle-ci est-ce que dans face à
l'inflation face à une crise agricole
avec des agriculteurs qui demandent des
prix rémunérateur c'est une bonne idée
et plus largement est-ce qu'il faut un
droit à l'alimentation Philippe Moulier
alors concernantexpérimentation je
seraai très prudent parce que je l'ai
pas étudié voilà mais j'ai quand même
quelques échos de ce qui se met en place
le principe du droit Mo me gêne beaucoup
c'estdire que je pense qu'il faut
surtout avoir des mesures
d'accompagnement pour que les gens
puissent se nourrir dignement je pense
que le fait de soutenir le monde
agricole et notamment tout ce qui est je
dirais échange de proximité est un point
essentiel par contre la méthode qui
concerne quelque part une forme de je
dirais de de de collectivisme autour de
tout ça le fait de dire à un moment
donné c'est encore des financements
publics qui viennent accompagner me pose
un certain nombre d'interrogations voilà
donc faut regarder qu'est-ce que sera le
le bilan de cette expérimentation mais
le principe général ça veut dire qu'à un
moment donné vous savez on rentre dans
les logiques où même chose que pour le
revenu universel hein c'estd que tout le
monde gagne pareil tout le mondeu pareil
les enjeux sur la table sont essentiels
je suis pas sûr que la méthode proposée
soit la bonne pour garantir en tous les
cas un revenu pour les monde agricole
vous savez on vient de parler à un
instant de la transmission de
l'espérance qu'on peut donner au monde
agricole leur expliquer de rentrer dans
un système de solidarité avec je dirais
un système de de de de suvention
supplémentaires indirect pour pouvoir
maintenir les revenus je crois que c'est
un vrai sujet qu'on pourrait évoquer
Jefferson vous aviez une autre question
sur l'une des annonce de Gabriel Atal
pendant son discours de politique
générale c'est la suppression de la
location de solidarité spécifique oui
exactement vous le savez ça c'est ça a
été annoncé pendant la déclaration de
politique générale auien vous venez de
le rappeler simplement Philippe Moulier
sachant que plus de la moitié des
bénéficiaires de cette allocation
spécifique ont plus de 50 ans est-ce que
vous y voyez un coup dur porté aux
chômeurs les plus âgés en tout cas les
seniors alors un coup dur non je je pris
pas ces terme là moi je fais partie de
ceux qui pensent qu'il faut repenser il
y a trop d'aide spécifiques on a même
perdu dans la démarche simplement
l'annonce a été faite moi aujourd'hui je
n'ai pas d'étude d'impact dans les mains
donc à la fois le le coup dur
éventuellement pour pour ce public là
mais je vous rappelle que lorsque vous
arrêtez cette allocation vous faites
basculer les gens dans le RSA le RSA est
financé par les départements et puis
l'état donc est-ce que c'est pas un
transfert quelque part du financement
par les départements mais surtout
derrière il y a des incidences
indirectes puisque vous pouvez cumuler
la location spécifique avec d'autres
aides je pense notamment la location
logement je pense à la location adultes
handicapé ce qui n'est pas le cas pour
les RSA enfin on voit bien que
aujourd'hui une simple annonce comme ça
moi je suis dans l'incapacité de juger
je pense qu'il faut de nouveau je suis
dans la même logique que le gouvernement
de dire comment est-ce qu'on fait pour
mettre de la pression pour que les gens
se tournent beaucoup plus vers l'emploi
mais la notion de solidarité est
importante on a évoqué la précariité
donc c'est un point essentiel voilà donc
je crois que les annonces se font comme
ça il faut se rendre compte que il y a
un effet domino il y a des incidences
directes et indirectes et tant que j'ai
pas l'étude dans les mains j'ai du mal à
à me saisir de ce sujet là en échange
quoi j'attends un peu mais très
rapidement je mettrai la Commission d'
soci au travail pour expertiser
justement toutes les incidences autour
de cet enjeul là de quelle manière oh je
pense qu'on va mettre en place à une
mission d'information j'ai pas de
calendrier j'attends d'avoir le contour
mais je crois qu'à un moment donné on
peut pas simplement voilà se dire c'est
une allocation en moins voilà les
incidences je vous dis sont directes et
indirectes et puis surtout que disent
les départements sur l'augmentation du
nombre de RSA on en est où voilà donc
tout ça a besoin d'être regardé de très
près justement un mot sur le RSA puisque
hier Catherine Varin la minise du
travail a annoncé un élargissement de
l'expérimentation du RSA sous condition
de 15 he d'activité ça passe de 18
départements à 47 d'ici la la fin du
mois c'est une bonne nouvelle oui c'est
une bonne nouvelle au SC on a été clair
on a accompagné cette mesure là
considérant qu'il fallait faire en sorte
que les bénéficiaires du RSA puissent
également s'engager dans une démarche
voilà de de retour à l'emploi
d'accompagnement de formation voilà et
donc je crois que c'est dans la logique
et moi je suis très heureux que on
puisse finalement mettre en application
ça sera aussi je rappelle c'est une
expérimentation donc on pourra en tirer
très rapidement les conclusions qui
permettront j'espère de démontrer que
cette démarche est utile une dernière
question plus politique de ferson oui
Orian vous l'avez évoqué lors de cet
entretien avec Philippe Moulier mais
restons nouv quitain avec François
baayerou il ne rentrera donc pas au
gouvernement simplement sur la la
question de cette majorité relative
Philippe Moulier est-ce qu'elle est
aujourd'hui fragilisée un peu plus
qu'elle ne l'était déjà oh je sais pas
si c'est un peu plus je crois que depuis
le début on a bien vu avec les
différents textes l'utilisation du 493
je le gouver est fragilisé par sa
majorité qui qui qui voilà on voit bien
queil y a une vraie difficulté ce qui on
voit d'ailleurs je considère même que le
le le Parlement de façon générale est
fragilisé parce que on voilà on le débat
se passe principalement au Sénat et en
face de nous on a un 493 donc on voit
bien qu'aujourd'hui il y a une logique
qui est quand même assez particulière et
là où je pense le gouvernement on a une
nécessité de pouvoir élargir quelque
part sa majorité bah partout ces
démarches par cette relation
particulière avec un certain nombre de
ténors bien on se rend compte qu'il
fragilise un peu plus voilà concant Baou
moi je je raconte juste une anecdote moi
j'étais j'étais j'ai eu un appel
téléphonique en famille hier mon père me
Palit de baayrou mon grand-père me Palit
Baayou et ben mes enfants je suis pas
sûr qu'ils ont envie qu'on parle encore
de Baayou voilà on n'est pas dans le
renouvellement des générations oui un
moment donné merci beaucoup merci
Jefferson merci d'avoir été avec nous
regarde la Une de Sud-Ouest consacré à
la fin des distributeurs c'est talire
dans Sud-Ouest merci Jefferson d'avoir
été avec nous merci Philippe mouiller
d'avoir été notre invité pendant cette
première demi-heure